it really is to our shame yeah a
rejection of our Christian Heritage here
in the US well and and but to his point
it's like this is a rejection of common
sense I mean this is a rejection this is
insanity yeah it's a kind of it's a
Madness that has overtaken us and and
it's I mean it's it's not even I mean
we've rejected Christianity too but it's
like we're down at the bottom of that
Barrel what's also going on is is
something that weighs on me often and
this is how I think the you know West
and Christian nations have been so
compromised and the best analogies you
know the boiling frog yes right and for
whoever doesn't know it's basically the
idea that if you throw a frog in boiling
water he jumps out but if you put him in
teid water and slowly boil it he stays
until he dies right and I think that's
what's going on what happens is you know
I was watching a video from the 19 like
60s and it's from California of all
places and it's a teacher or some kind
of school administrator warning children
about homosexuality I seen that yes they
smoke yeah and he's like and if you're
engaged or doing anything with any of
these homosexuals you know and it's they
had commercials warning children okay
how did we get to that to where we're
here but I'll tell you how we didn't get
there they didn't throw stuff on
us right away because that would have
been throwing the frog in the boiling
water and we would have gotten it and
jumped out but they did it very very
slowly they first started oh actually
home psycholog is a normal thing they're
just born that way and then the you know
the medical establishment and the
psychologist same guys who got covid you
know shoved down our throat told us it's
absolutely normal then the sitcom
started be you they showed them in a
sympathetic way and then came okay and
then every movie you saw there it was
and then they started turning the heat
up till they got us to where we're at
now the sad part is and and here's the
sad part because when so again think of
the heat thing if you put a let's say
you put a frog in 200 degrees and he's
really hot and let's say normal is like
whatever 70 okay if you bring it down to
120 he's going to be grateful but it's
still siing so they got us they're like
throwing this insane stuff at us the
trans stuff the pronoun stuff to the
point that once goes away oh we're happy
to accept normal homosexuality that's
awesome that's perfect we'll take that
because it's kind of lowering the heat
even though in reality it's still pretty
bad de or whatever so I think that's
been going on that kind of approach has
been totally compromising American
civilization we've talked about this a
fair bit on on here just because of I
mean the the craziness of how Trump you
know these these executive orders that
you have to use the right pronouns or
what you know it's like I mean man is a
man the insanity that we like that's a
that's a win yeah for us to be happy
about that s exactly and and I think
also and so with that I mean on the one
hand you you you can be grateful like
okay there's some sanity and the other
on the other hand it's like yeah this is
insane that we're here and I think the
Temptation Of course is your point is
now that it's 150 degrees all right
we're fine it's just normal
homosexuality it's just you know but we
don't realize that it's still hot right
it's really bad you you can't you can't
defy the law of God which is the law of
nature you cannot you cannot defy that a
little bit and be in a safe place yeah
like you know just like it's just a
little bit of defiance little bit of
gravity Defiance it's like no but you're
that's already a small bit of Madness
you're saying I can live in this world
and I can be blessed and defy the one
who made me and the one who made this
world that's right and and so it's like
though that is a slippery slope and and
so even if you turn it back to 150
degrees it's like you know that is going
to go right back up to 200 again it's
going to go right back up to Boiling
again U just give it a few you know
they're just they're doing the musle
game I'm in Mecca right
now I'm Mecca what do you want from me
yeah I I preach peace but there's a
Medina but once uh you know once we're
in power and you're not guess what we're
now we're in Medina now we're in Medina